moscou n'avait pas encore réagi à cette
annonce du pentagone qui comptent
fournir une aide militaire de 125
millions de dollars à l'ukraine
et c'est maintenant chose faite la
porte-parole de la diplomatie russe a
pris acte de cette décision qui concerne
deux pays souverains même si au passage
elle a noté que ce n'était peut-être pas
de matériel militaire dont le peuple
ukrainien avait le plus besoin en ce
moment ma technique ce que ça traîne
histoire quatre heures après soit
premièrement une coopération militaire
et technique entre deux états souverains
n'est réglementée que par leur accord
car il s'agit d'une coopération entre
deux gouvernements légitimes
parallèlement nous devons garder à
l'esprit que comme il s'agit de
l'ukraine nous parlons ici d'un pays où
le conflit se poursuit il est toujours
dans sa phase active et nous suivons
bien sûr les événements récents en
ukraine et ils sont nombreux à ne pas
nous inspirer d'optimisme la barre haute
au contraire ils sont pour nous un signe
extrêmement inquiétant qui témoigne de
la situation sur place
quant à la générosité comme vous l'avait
qualifiée des états unis qui fournissent
des armes à l'ukraine je tiens à
souligner qu'il s'agit d'une décision
prise par les capitales des deux états
mais puisqu'on vous me le demandez je
vous dirais que ces derniers mois les
citoyen ukrainien avait plutôt besoin de
vaccination que de livraisons d'armes
grâce new kind of shipping nathalie vox
famille éloignée à yves pascal oger
cette aide militaire américaine devrait
prendre la forme entre autres de deux
navires patrouilleurs mark iv destiné à
la défense des eaux territoriales
ukrainienne seul intervient dans un
contexte déjà très tendu en mer noire on
se souvient de l'incident de kertch fin
quand la marine russe avait arraisonné
plusieurs navires militaires ukrainien
faisant 24 prisonniers et plus
globalement les relations restent très
délicate entre moscou et kiev
alors que la mise en oeuvre des accords
de minsk est toujours au point mort